GOT TO GET  A BIG ONPLAYING WEL
>> Dominique: AND TEAMS LIKE
THIS DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
LOSE.
THAT
HE STILL HAD THE BALL IN HIS
HAND.
IT   WE ARE SHOWING THE GREA WH.
>>THIS IS HERBERT JONES.
THAT IS TO THE 12
ASSISTS.
>> K COMMUNICATOR, ANDLEY.
>> PICKED.
HAMIDOU DIALLO WITH A THREE
DECISIONS AT THE TO
HERE'S  ANOTHER LOOK  --
>> Matt: JUST HUNGRY, RIGHT?
JAKOB POELT WILL TRY FROM
MIDCOURT.
AND HE GOT
>> Ryan: THERE IS SIAKAM.
>> Bob: YEAH.
NOW YOU SEE  THINK H H HONY EDW.
DETERMINE THE SOBERER IN NAZ WA
LIKE NAZ THEN THIS ROAD TO THE .
WATCH AYO OUT HERE WAIT FOR HIM
AND GET UP OR GET OUT OF THE NIR
HIM, AND HE IS STILL DOWN.
BLOCKED BY JOKIC.
AND FUMBLED OUT OF BOUNDS.
>> Scott: THIS IS ONE OF THE
GREATEST
UNIQUE HE AND HIS GAME ARE.
>> Kate: THE OFFENSIVE